is about he was famously described as
the most dangerous man in America for
the knowledge the military analysts
possessed who then shared some of
Washington's best secrets with the rest
of the world
Daniel Ellsberg exposed how four
successive U.S presidents lied about
White House policy in Vietnam
Ellsberg worked on the now Infamous
Pentagon Papers secretly photocopying 7
000 Pages which he then gave to the New
York Times in 1971.
in doing so he became Public Enemy
Number One Tucson
even former U.S president Richard Nixon
painted a Target on ellsberg's back
what making national heroes out of those
who steal secrets and publish them in
the newspaper
in January 1973 Ellsberg was charged
with theft and conspiracy under the
Espionage Act of 1917.
but in a landmark ruling the U.S Supreme
Court dismissed ellsberg's case and
upheld the right to the media to publish
the documents
but the persecution of whistleblowers
had begun I identify very strongly with
Edward Snowden and with Chelsea Manning
when Chelsea Manning said to her
informant she was ready to go to prison
for life or even be executed quote to
get out this information I thought I
haven't heard anyone else say that for
40 years that's the way I felt in 1969
and 1971.
in the late 1950s Ellsberg was the
brains behind America's top secret
operational plan for all-out nuclear war
with China and the Soviet Union
he held on to those classified documents
for 50 years only releasing them in 2021
he persistently questioned the motives
behind War something two decades of
fighting in Afghanistan and the war in
Ukraine raises today
uh we control needle pretty much and
NATO gives us an excuse and a reason to
sell enormous amounts of arms he went
from an Ardent Cold War Warrior to
campaigning for peace
and while he shared so much of what
those in the corridors of power want to
keep from the world he's sure to take
some secrets with him to the Grave in
Richardson